[Musique]
on est d'accord il y a des styles de
musique qui ont mal vieilli et peut-être
que celle que tu écoutes aujourd'hui
décroche à des enfants une grimace de
dégoût la musique qui voulut a duré les
nouvelles technologies pourrait
complètement la révolutionner alors avec
l'ami antoine on a tenté d'imaginer ce à
quoi pourrait ressembler la musique du
futur
la musique du futur sera elle composée
par des ordinateurs
1997 l'ia gagne aux échecs tu 2005 l'ia
c'est conduire une voiture
2017 l'ias est rédigé des articles de
presse presque indiscernable d'un
journaliste humain combien de temps
avant que l'intelligence artificielle ne
s'emparent de la création musicale pour
nous imiter dans ce domaine également en
fait pour qu'un ordinateur compose de la
musique même pas besoin d'intelligence
artificielle un modèle mathématique très
simple suffit à faire le boulot ça
s'appelle les chaînes de markov et tu
vas voir tu les connais déjà sans savoir
imaginons que tu donnes à ton ordinateur
des paroles de toutes les chansons de
nec feu il va parcourir tous les maux et
regarder pour chacun quel est le mot qui
s'enchaînent juste après par exemple on
est suivi de dera
mais aussi de se
ses ou
serait ce qu on serait même
une fois qu'il a tracé les liens entre
tous les maux ton ordinateur peut
maintenant lâché un freestyle au klm
quelle ironie du range possession je
veux plus lui d'oublier
je touche avec mes gars solide je touche
avec un lascar saint
jacques
j'écrase
alors ça c'est la snec ce nom bon le
problème c'est que ça veut pas dire
grand chose c'est normal le principe
d'une chaîne mark up c'est que pour
continuer la phrase l'ordinateur ne
regarde que le dernier maillon le
dernier mot et ne se soucie jamais du
reste de la chaîne du coup hockey les
mots s'enchaînent bien mais le sens
global est éclatée c'est ce système qui
utilise la barre de prédiction de ton
téléphone tu tapes un début de mots et
la machine taux de propose une suite
logique en ayant analysé t habitude
d'écrire et c'est en commentaire de
taper un message qui commence par trash
et seulement avec ses prédictions tué
râle le français correct tu retrouves
sûrement des expressions préférées mais
la phrase ne veut pas dire grand chose
heureusement tu vas voir qu'on a trouvé
des tricks pour résoudre ce problème
changeons d'exemple au lieu des mots
prenons des notes de musique ont fourni
à l'ordinateur toutes les oeuvres de
bach et voici ce qu'il nous sort
c'est pas parfait mais en vrai lien un
truc c'est normal en faisant d'une note
à note difficile d'être cohérent on va
donc utiliser unia qui bosse à
différentes échelles d'abord elle met en
place les chaînons couplet refrain puis
les enchaînements d'accords les mesures
et enfin les notes pendant ce processus
elle doit doser subtilement suite
d'accords classique et progression
inattendue pour rendre la musique
harmonieuse mais sans qu'on ne se lasse
à l'écouté c'est ce qu'a tenté huawei en
entraînant une intelligence artificielle
a tellement imité le compositeur
emblématique franz schubert qu'elle
pouvait presque prêt shot les
enchaînements dansés morceaux elle a
ainsi pu écrire la fin d'une oeuvre
mythique qu'il avait laissée inachevée à
sa mort la huitième symphonie de
schubert
l'iap même écrire un morceau entier sony
a sorti en 2018 un album entier de
musique composée par un tel programme
comme ce titre à 2 millions de vues
inspiré des beatles qu'on vous invite à
aller écouter
[Musique]
pas étonnant que ça sème l'organisme qui
gère les droits d'auteur a déjà reconnu
officiellement un premier artiste
virtuel le concept est prometteur mais
la musique en swan encore rien de
révolutionnaire d'autant plus que le
processus de création est encore
largement supervisés par des
compositeurs humain mais dans quelques
années il y as pourra composer de la
musique en complète autonomie il suffira
de donner une sélection d'artistes ou
d'ambiance à ton ordinateur pour qu'il
te sortent instantanément un album
inédit enfin jeudi dans quelques années
mais en fait c'est déjà possible la
société open et harry fondée entre
autres par elon musk a mis à disposition
du public jukebox une intelligence
artificielle entraîné à générer de la
musique quand on lui donne un artiste et
des paroles avec des résultats mitigés
ça donne parfois l'impression d'être
bourrée
[Musique]
toutefois on va pas se mentir en
écoutant tous ces morceaux j'ai
l'impression qu'il manque quelque chose
en fait cette technologie est illimité
cas il ne suffit pas de sortir du
conservatoire en connaissant toutes les
codes de la musique classique pour faire
du mozart le mystère du génie humain ne
se conforment à aucune règle mais une
chose est certaine il provoque l'émotion
la musique c'est aussi un instant de
partage entre l'artiste et le spectateur
une conversation d'humain à humain
difficile de partager les sentiments
d'un ordinateur qui nous parle de son
véhicule dans la stricte ou qu'ils nous
chantent ses peines de coeur l'émotion
est un paramètre clé qui échappera
probablement toujours alliée à la
conscience les artistes n'ont donc pas à
s'inquiéter qu'une machine leur vole
leur job ils nous font plutôt penser
liga comme aide un outil plutôt qu'une
fin en soi à partir d'un simple portable
tu pourras te laisser guider croiser les
styles crée une atmosphère unique ou
convoquer un orchestre entier du bout
des doigts bref expérimenté à l'infini
et sans effort faut-il complètement
réinventé la musique s'il y arrive a si
bien manipuler de la musique c'est parce
qu'il suffit de gratter un peu une
partition pour s'apercevoir que cet art
repose essentiellement sur les maths le
premier à vraiment résoudre
rigoureusement ce problème vous le
connaissez sûrement c'est pythagore oui
le mec au triangle la légende raconte
qu'un jour qu'il passait devant un
atelier de forgeron en entendant les
coups des marteaux sur les enclumes il a
remarqué que certains coûts allaient
bien ensemble
alors que d'autres aient été peu
agréable en pesant alors les marteaux il
fut surpris de constater que ceux qui
sonnaient harmonieusement avait des
masses parfaitement proportionnelle y
compris ainsi que la science de la
musique résider dans la proportion est
le rapport dénombre par exemple pour
passer de doha sol il faut multiplier la
fréquence par trois demis de doha fin on
multiplie par quatre tiers et ainsi de
suite toujours des fractions simple ça
alors permis à pythagore de démontrer
mathématiquement des questions de base
les notes de musique de ré mi fa sol la
si pourquoi il y en aurait pas une de
plus pourquoi sur le clavier d'un piano
on a l'impression que par endroits il
des touches noires il va alors démontré
toute la théorie mathématique soutient
la musique en montrant que 12 notes
serait un cycle parfait effet si on
démarre de dos est à chaque saut ou
multiplient la fréquence par trois
demies on arrive à placer les 12 notes
de la gamme et à retomber sur un dos à
l'arrivée la boucle est bouclée enfin
presque il se cache une coquille dans
toute cette belle théorie en réalité
pythagore à un peu arrondi ses calculs
parce que c'était le seul moyen pour que
ça fonctionne sauveur
il faut alors rallonger un petit chouya
en plus la dernière partie pour
parfaitement bouclé le cercle
l'approximation n'est que de 1% pas de
quoi en faire un drame pourtant notre
oreille est assez sensible pour être
gêné dans la gamme de pythagore
certaines notes sonne faux écoutez
là c'est comme ça devrait être
parfaitement juste
[Musique]
là c'est avec l'approximation de
pythagore - c'est comme s'il manquait un
petit espace entre quelques touches du
piano ces intervalles qui sonne faux on
appelle ça le loup et pendant des
siècles les compositeurs devait faire en
sorte d'éviter à tout prix cette
combinaison de notes au risque de
déclencher des grincements dans
l'auditoire alors pourquoi on n'a pas
décidé de régler le problème une fois
pour toutes en accordant mieux les
instruments parce que les maths sont
impitoyables il n'existe aucune gamme
qui sonnera parfaitement justes qui
refermera parfaitement le cycle les
musiciens modernes ont quand même trouvé
une astuce pour camoufler l'erreur au
lieu d'avoir certaines notes bien fausse
on a choisi de diluer l'erreur la
répartir sur toutes les notes pour
qu'elle devienne moins choquant oui
aujourd'hui plus aucun d'intervalle
n'est complètement juste ils ne sont
juste assez pour que ça ne choque plus
presque tout ce que vous écoutez
aujourd'hui est faux sauf que les
mathématiques ont peut-être des
solutions solutions un rendre tous les
intervalles juste en rajoutant des notes
ainsi chaque note existerait en
plusieurs exemplaires différent d'un
chouïa un clavier dont les notes sont
différentes selon le contexte où elles
sont jouées et ça existe déjà ça
s'appelle un clavier micro tonale
[Musique]
solution 2 assumer ces post notes et
jouer avec c'est ce que fait ce célèbre
trompettiste qui a rajouté un piston à
sa trompette pour atteindre des notes au
quart de ton c'est à dire celles situées
dans les interstices des notes
traditionnel cx de même déjà dans
d'autres cultures solution 3 pourquoi ne
pas repenser entièrement la théorie
reconstruire des gammes à 24 notes ou
même 85 verges cette note là encore ça
existe malheureusement le business de la
musique non courage pas du tout à
prendre ce genre d'initiatives et pousse
à l'uniformisation les hits planétaires
qui font vendre sont ceux qui ne sortent
pas des sentiers battus afin de plaire à
un maximum de personnes c'est comme ça
qu'on se retrouve avec des suites
d'accords passe partout que tout le
monde reprend sans expérimenter de
nouvelles choses comme les quatre
accords magique on sort à toutes les
sauces peut-être que le futur de
l'industrie musicale
dans fin aux et écouter et composer de
la musique qui sort des sentiers battus
pour explorer les continents vierge de
la musique en 2050 comme ans et coûtera
ton la musique si comme moi vous écoutez
de la musique tous les jours vous
connaissez sûrement la galère de trouver
la bonne playlist qui convient à votre
mode du moment grâce à liés à ce
problème ne se posera plus jamais on
peut imaginer que ta montre connectés
sera analysé t signaux biologique pour
déterminer l'état physiologique dans
lequel tu es un pouls rapide des petits
tremblements elle te proposera un
morceau apaisant pour calmer ses nerfs
suivante à réaction elle va apprendre
quels sont les musiques qui fonctionne
le mieux pour toi est calibré une
playlist unique mise à jour en
permanence pour te proposer le morceau
parmi des centaines de millions la
musique dont tu as des besoins sans même
le savoir elle pourrait même adapté en
direct le titre que tu écoutes le rendre
plus doux ou plus intime plus
entraînants et ça existe déjà que
l'application riveraine synchronise en
direct le rythme de la musique avec
celui de taff foulée ça te met dans le
flou pour te permettre de booster
performance cette nouvelle façon d'avoir
la musique dans la peau pourrait aussi
passer par les dispositifs qui nous
permettent d'entendre la musique oubliez
les casques et écouteurs vous avez
sûrement entendu parler récemment de ses
écouteurs à conduction osseuse par
exemple ce mec même s'il n'a rien dans
les oreilles en temps quand même sa zik
parce que le casque transmet les
vibrations de la musique à travers les
haut de son crâne si tu as un diapason
tu peux t'amuser à tester ce phénomène
chez toi
il ya fort à parier que la prochaine
étape est que ces écouteurs soit
directement des implants sous cutanés on
pourra imaginer que grâce à une
opération on augmente on wii grâce à une
oreille 2.0 cela pourrit par exemple
nous permettre d'entendre des sons qui
nous étaient inaccessibles comme les
ultrasons ça vous paraît de la
science-fiction portant un bios à coeur
l'a déjà fait il ya presque dix ans il
s'est même doté d'un système
d'écholocalisation qui lui permet de se
repérer grâce aux sons comme les chauves
souris les instruments de musique
pourrait bien suivre la même tendance et
devenir une extension de ton corps on
pourrait aussi rêver de cordes vocales
augmenté auto tune et les musiciens
pourront de plus en plus faire corps
avec leur instrument
[Musique]
oui cette scène dans le cinquième
élément cette diva extraterrestre arrive
à descendre très bas dans les graves
mais aussi à monter très aigu rapidement
aucun être humain n'est capable de
chanter cette terre
[Musique]
non
et bien un implant pourrait permettre un
autre voie d'atteindre un tel registre
lors de certains concerts des capteurs
de mouvements permettent également aux
artistes d'animer en direct un avatar
virtuel à leur effigie et ça pourrait
révolutionner notre façon d'assister à
des concerts à l'image du concert
virtuel de tralee scott qui a eu lieu
sur forte night la foule virtuelle
présente ce jour-là comptait plus de 27
millions de joueurs un regroupement
monumentale qui n'auraient jamais pu
avoir lieu dans un concert traditionnel
mais pourtant travis coop n'a pas
inventé le concept du chanteur
dématérialisée en 2012 le festival
coachella avait ressuscité le rappeur
tupac et grâce à un hologramme il avait
tenu la scène avec snoop dogg dr dre
alors qu'ils étaient décédées plus de
quinze ans auparavant même si une partie
du public est mal à l'aise devant ses
concerts virtuels le marché est en plein
essor et il est probable que dans les
quelques années il suffira donc il est
un casque vr pour aller à un concert
depuis son salon pourra s'immerger dans
une foule virtuel venus du monde entier
survolé la scène avoir accès aux
coulisses ou interagir en votant pour le
prochain morceau reste à savoir si de
tels concerts virtuels pourront
reproduire la chaleur de la foule et
l'expérience unique du spectacle vivant
pourtant sur un casque vert à part
betriber et le porno je n'ai jamais voir
les nombreux concerts vr qui ont déjà
lieu d'ailleurs un jour il pourrait n'y
avoir plus rien de vivant dans ses
spectacles les stars qu'on irait voir
serait complètement artificielle comme
ce groupe de métal 100% métallique ou
encore hatsune miku dont la voix est
générée par un logiciel de synthèse
[Musique]
phénomène mondial elle est considérée
par des milliers d'internautes comme des
véritables chanteuse et donne même des
concerts en hologramme bref quand on
regarde bien l'écrasante majorité de la
musique d'aujourd'hui avec nos gammes de
cette note et les concerts sur scène on
se rend compte que c'est n'est qu'une
goutte dans les possibilités qui
s'offrent à nous d'autant plus que la
théorie des accords qui structurent new
music n'a pas vraiment évolué depuis bac
la musique numérique pourrait bien
permettre aux musiciens d'explorer cet
univers des possibilités en leur donnant
les moyens de devenir un archéologue du
monde musical un véritable sculpteur de
sons le savez je suis doctorat en
mathématiques et j'anime une grosse
association de mathématiques en france
animat ce sujet sur la musique a été
l'occasion pour moi de vous montrer que
ma discipline peut dépasser les manuels
scolaires et se cacher dans la pop
culture et c'est pour ça je voulais
faire une petite dédicace du jeu
français tales of synap ce qui vient de
sortir sur steam et ni tête de switch un
jeu indépendant qui mêle mathématiques
plateforme et univers onirique on a reçu
la directrice artistique lors d'une
émission de parlons matin avec mon
association je tenais absolument à vous
le faire découvrir et en faire une
petite pub ici au vu du travail
monstrueux qu'ils ont fournis j'y mets
le lien en descriptions ça vous
intéresse n'hésitez pas à les voir aller
c'est tout pour moi like et abonnez-vous
à les amis ciao
[Musique]